Hello Freak bitches
calling tomorrow night.
Yeah. Don't talk travel with
Henry Rollins. Don't you
feel like a townie? God,
that guy's been around, hasn't it?
Do you know what he does every year?
Picks a spot on the map. Let's go like
that. Bali causes as travel agent.
What can we were going on in Bali and he
just flies out to Bali by himself with
a laptop and a camera pair of underwear.
Toothbrush just lives there. That's good.
Didn't your boy are already do the same
thing because of Henry Rollins? Yeah.
Are you went super deep? You wouldn't
even deeper. He went for four months.
I was like, I'll show
you. I can be wrong much.
We're looking for why you looking
for why fight and your destination.
You're not trapped. Ari.
Shaffir fuck your Wifi.
Fuck your phone if you really want
to travel. Yeah, really? Yeah.
Can't you've traveled with
a phone [inaudible] I travel
all the time and I like,
I'd rather stay home.
Once you travel to a thousand cities,
you realize it's an illusion. Everyone's
trying to travel to where I live.
People are coming from Australia and I'm
going to fucking Tahiti French brother.
You know what?
You're walking through the airport and
you see the destination that the be all
end all some dude's feet
on a fucking bad ass beach.
Like that's, that's the the goal. Yup.
And then when you get there either
like you realize, wait a minute,
that cutting off,
they framed off like the people trying
to sell you a fucking a crocodile
unloading.
Be like,
I've done it.
Dot. That's right. Dot.
I went to Thailand. I go,
I'm going to go to dessert on a fucking
island on Thailand. And everyone said,
yeah, you can. I go where they go,
you need to fucking take a cap.
Three hours jumped in a cab,
three hours I'm gone and we finally
get to go where the islands, oh,
you want to go to the island?
Yeah. Yeah. I'm thinking, oh,
I don't give a fuck how much it
costs. It's just go, it's cheaper.
If you go on a big ferry to this island
or you could take a speed bottle,
fucking speed boat, let's go. Boom.
I'm videotaping everything
they want him to speak on.
I want to go on this fucking
ion that I see at the airport.
I see him all the time. I don't give a
fuck. I'm getting book money and Shit.
I don't give a shit. Fuck
Thailand nonstop. I go,
I'm going to go on a fucking
island. You get there, boom.
And there's 200 other people there. Yup.
And there's like snack bars and shit.
The secret is [inaudible] son
go.
This is the Thailand.
There you go.
Out there was a Tracy.
That's crazy. It was a trick.
I spend fucking all day finding this
fucking dude that was on a speed boat
thinking they were going to
take me to this island. Yeah.
Do you remember that was going to be
alone, beat you boy, Jason from England,
the mole Deeves got to go to the mall.
Deeves Jesus Christ ability.
Yeah.